[Music]
Democrats are having serious for Gretz
about forcing former senator Al Franken
of Minnesota out of office Frank and
resigned back in 2017 over sexual
misconduct allegations after widespread
pressure from within his own party but
now a New Yorker article reveals several
Democratic senators wish he never
stepped aside and Franken says he quote
absolutely regrets and quote his
decision while adding and here I'm
quoting again the idea that anybody who
accuses someone if something is always
right that's not the case that isn't
reality end quote
now while some Democrats say they made a
mistake one of frankenz biggest critics
senator Kirsten Gillibrand is doubling
down daddy franky was in tonight
whether to wait out his ethics committee
hearing whether to wait for his next
election the decision I made is whether
or not to carry his water and stay
silent and to somehow blame me for a
man's actions and a man's decision it's
pretty absurd Jesse I do you think
Franken should've resigned he didn't
have anything in a court of law no due
process so I'm thinking sometimes you
know these cases can be subjective
because times changed perspective
changing so unite get people who said
yeah he should get out saying yeah I'm
not sure well he was pretty low on the
me2 totem pole I think everybody agrees
with that but this was in the context of
the Democrats wanting to look pure while
they were trying to attack Roy Moore and
it was fresh off the heels of the
Weinstein situation so they were gonna
get killed with what about isms if they
had stuck behind al franken at this
table no in the media but I think the
the real deal is that Jane Mayer who did
this piece is not a real journalist
she's an advocate for Democrats this was
a puff piece to rehab his image in his
career and she didn't treat anybody the
same way as she would have treated Al
Franken why doesn't she look at some of
the sexual harassment lawsuits
settlements in Congress that the
taxpayers have to pay for no she was a
real headache for the Bush
administration slimed CIA agents led
Obama off the hook and now she's back
helping Trump helping people who hate
Trump this is what happens here with
Democrats they only care about due
process for Democrats whenever there's
an accusation against the Republican
it's conviction she says she poked holes
in the accusers story she what hole she
the accuser said the photo with this was
taken December 24th she says oh no it
was taken December 21st
I mean I think there were much more
holes poked in the Cavanaugh accusers
story than that but ultimately the me2
movements still strong I think maybe
it's swinging a little back and it's not
as hysterical as it used to be but men
now I think are behaving better and
women are reporting things immediately
but I still think bring back the slap
roll once a man gets fresh slap them
right in the face
so but Katie you know I'm thinking to
myself about standards now Jessie
rightly mentioned that Jane Mayer had
written a piece about the cabin ah yeah
and so I'm thinking to myself what is
the standard for elected officials with
regard to inappropriate sexual behavior
because it looks to me like you know
when the charges against the Democrat
you don't get away but if it's against
Cavanaugh yes get away where's the due
process well first of all we should
mention that the Cavanaugh case the
Senate Judiciary Committee came out with
the four hundred page report after all
of the committee hearings were over and
he was confirmed showing that not a
single accusation against him panned out
and didn't have any kind of evidence so
you asked what the standard is the
standard is evidence not jumping to
conclusions not necessarily believing
women but taking them seriously making
sure you weigh both sides of the story
but there was a writer who's claiming to
be a journalist that there was no such
evidence presented in the Franken case
there were photos that were not
represented there was no information
there's no information or evidence
presented at all outside of accusations
from 30 years ago and in fact there was
lots of evidence to show that they were
connected the accusers two Democrats who
were trying to take down Supreme Court
justice Brett Kavanaugh so the standard
is everybody take a breath if we want
women to actually be taken seriously you
cannot continue to push forward false
allegations or jump to conclusions
because it actually hurts people who
have real cases against men who are
abusers or who are sexual predators so
you think he should have resigned I
don't know I don't know what he should
have done he definitely didn't get the
due process that he should've and for
kirsten gillibrand
to sit there and say that you know I had
nothing to do with it she was one of the
first people to call for she was the
first and she was leading the charge on
it so she certainly had something to do
with the pressure on him so vague and
trump's been accused many times he
denies in every case so all you have to
do is the night and then the women
aren't heard and you know is that all
you want it really is that fear I think
that the women have been heard in plenty
of forums quite frankly one and I will
say this about Al Franken what's the
point of this article in The New Yorker
poor
he's the victim let's think when you
talk about that photo of Lin tweed and
she was asleep and he got away with it
in part and they're making excuses for
it now because oh he's a comedian there
were seven other accusers which are
mentioned in the article and what is the
point of this article in The New Yorker
to send the message to Democrats and
liberal men of like next time we'll go
easy on you but to the Republicans they
will bake fry and microwave you until
there is nothing left well I think he's
president still I think I think they're
still there all right so Greg oh yeah I
was thinking about this and I thought to
myself well what sanctions are in place
like you know you get someone like that
guy Steve King with all of his white
nationalist writer Republicans have
sanction and stripped them but they
don't make him resign the Democrats made
franken get out there make him do it his
party ate him alive in the it's the
shoot first ask questions later at world
of the me to movement he was right there
however he's not innocent I mean I know
personally two people he did this to
okay we talked about it not just Leanne
we know that you know Kathy Lee got he
it Frank different were alive today he
would beat the crap out of Al Franken so
I think everybody knew this about Al
Franken that he used to he used to grab
people kiss me be kissed but he bragged
about it on Howard Stern or he talked
about it in the green room which was
then brought up on Howard Stern and
there is visual evidence that Jane Mayer
are ignored
she used gossip to destroy Cavanaugh but
knows there's actually stories about Al
Franken I wish she had due process I
wish she stuck around I wish he had
actually been questioned and we could
have seen with this go but I think of
like a lot of people he had the
progressive Pig pass which is like Bill
Clinton Harvey Weinstein Epstein they
survive and thrive as long as you
support Democrats they look the other
way so you're saying you thought he
should have had due process yeah we're
leaving yeah but I I think that there
was there he was guilty but he should
have gone through he should have stuck
around but maybe he knew maybe he knew
it was gonna get ugly well you can't say
that Gregg isn't fair